good evening members members of the
public and officers seven o'clock and
welcome to this planning committee
meeting on the 19th of October
2022
as always a little bit of information
for yourselves which I think you all
know by now but we have to do it if the
fire alarm is activated please vacate
the offices via the stairs opposite the
lifts will use a security door to my
right assemble on holy Square green
obviously the council offices and an
officer will
be in touch with your come and grab you
if um you know we can carry on
please please I will say we've been live
streamed
um so um
I think you know what I mean by that um
uh filming does anybody intend filming
okay thank you for that restriction of
course on mobile phones could you please
make sure your mobile phones are turned
to silent and please do not use them
during the meeting
and while it's in progress members are
requesting to speak under Council
procedure 20.1
um I don't see any other members here
tonight
um please confirm no
no thank you very much
I should have said a welcome Charles on
stage tonight because
our other Clark is on holiday
um public speaking there are no requests
that have been received for public
speaking
agenda item one apologies for absence
councilor Everett councilor Pat Moore is
unwell so she sends apologies thank you
any other at all no
thank you agenda item two any
Declarations of Interest
none agenda item three do members agree
at the minutes of the planning committee
which was held here on the 21st of
September 2022 be approved as a correct
record could I have a proposer please
few hands going up account take cancer
sharp second to please
councilor Keane all agree
thank you members agenda item four
planning application for 26 Granville
way broadstairs
I will ask the planning officer which I
understand all tonight is with Emma
I haven't asked Mr Livingston to speak
at all because you can't hear him hear
whatever else so
um Emma thank you
thank you chairman uh this application
is for 26 Grenville way it was brought
uh before members
um a few committees ago the application
was for a single story front extension
and two single story rear extensions so
this is a site here fronted onto
Grenville way and this is
um the property in this location here
and you can see it again in this
location here so the previous when it
was previously bought before members it
was for a single story extension that
followed on from The Ridge and Eaves of
the existing building although there had
been some amendments to the roof level
to reduce it and create a flat roof to
reduce the height at Ridge level at that
point there and there was a single story
extension to the rear of the garage and
to the front of the property so this is
the front of the property here the
proposal was for an extension that
infield this area in front of the front
door but it was set back behind the
existing garage again a flat roof that's
tied in with the design of the existing
projections to the front
um and this is the block plan so what's
happened since the application was
bought before members is
um members were concerned with the rear
extension the impact it would have had
on the light and Outlook from the
neighboring property
um in this location here from their side
kitchen window
um so members were Keen to see the roof
design amended to become a flat roof
um what has actually happened is that
the amended plans have been submitting
submitted emitting the rear extension so
that's no longer part of this
application and instead that extension
has come to us as part of a lawful
development certificate application they
did need to reduce the depth of the
extension in order for it to be
permitted development but it did comply
with all the requirements and that has
now been approved so they they can now
build the extension under permitted
development rights so this application
now is solely for the extension to the
front which was that that flat roof
single story extension in that location
here and for a very small extension to
the rear of the garage that's that's all
these applications now for
um so this is the the existing plan and
this is the proposed plan so this is the
extension here to the rear of the garage
and you can see this is the extension at
the front of the property
um so it's a 2.95 meter deep extension
but again you can see the fact it
doesn't project beyond the front garage
and therefore is not considered to be
severely detrimental to the the
character of the area
and in terms of the rear extension
that's not like to be visible from um
from the road
and then this is just the front of the
existing front Innovation and the
proposed so that's the design of the
front extension again you can see it's
in keeping with the design of the
existing garage
and then this is the existing side
elevation so you can see this is a
garage projection at the front at the
moment and this is um the proposed
extension
and then this is the other side existing
and then this is now with the small
garage rear extension in this location
here so everything's tying up with the
design of the existing
um garage and then this is the rear and
now you can see there's no extension to
the rear of this location just here to
the rear of the existing garage so um
it's not consider that there'd be any
significant impact upon Neighbors from
these changes so I'll just go quickly
back to the block plan so you can see
it's a very modest extensions the rear
of the garage
um it's not effective there's a two
meter or so distance to the neighboring
property here it's an oxidative that
this extension would significantly
impact on any lighter Outlook from the
side windows of this neighboring
property and this front extension is set
in from the neighbor so again from the
neighboring front windows here they're
not even going to be able to really get
a view of that front extension
um so it's considered to be
um acceptable and it's recommended for
approval thank you uh thank you Anna I
moved the officer's recommendation as
you heard is for approval could the vice
chair please second oh second nature
thank you Council Colin cook members do
you wish to debate
okay so those are all in favor please
show
anybody against
abstentions nope I'm poor as well that
is courage thank you members
uh agenda item five is any site visits
which will take place on Friday the 4th
of November so anything tonight so site
visit 4th of November normally at 9 30
in the morning
uh now I'm going to look at Mr
Livingston now the point of information
on the planet now question we're looking
at tonight thank you thank you Tim
um point of information for members on
schedule item 5C which is Addington
Street Garage uh Wesley was Addington
place so following Works occurring on
site regarding the boundary wall and
Hope Place the council has received a
plan showing details of the proposed
Flint wall on the site boundary
therefore this plan showing the Flint
wall to replace the non-flint section of
the boundary wall is proposed to be
inserted into condition 16 on the
application so that condition will now
read the existing Flint wall on the
Northern boundary of the site are
joining her for Place she'll be retained
with the partial demolished section of
the wall reconstructed using flint and
brickwork as shown on plan 482
pln220 received on the 18th of October
2022 prior to the first occupational
development with details of the pointing
of the wall submitted to prior to
construction and approved in writing by
the local planning Authority the wall
should be constructed in accordance with
the approved details and the ground of
that condition is to safeguard the
special character appearance of the area
as a conservation area in accordance
with policy he02 with the final local
plan and advice within the mppf so
condition 16 is updated in the office of
recommendation and all the details will
be shown to members if the application
is discussed thank you chair uh thank
you Ian you gather I'm sitting next to
Louis Armstrong tonight
um voice like that
um public speaking as there is no public
speaking on any of the schedule or items
this evening I will call upon the Clark
and Charles to read out the planned
applications if a member wishes to
resolve Reserve an application will they
please call out as he reads Charles
thank you chair
Hearts down Leisure Center hasdown Park
Market
land to the north of Fairlawn Road and
West of Northwood Road broadstairs
thank you
the last one
Addington Street Garage went to
Westcliff Works Arlington Place Ramsgate
nope
thank you thank you Charles
could I have a proposal that the
applications that have not been reserved
be determined in accordance with the
officer's recommendation uh could I have
a second to please councilor Coleman
cook members agree
I think I do as well thank you for that
so right so we're moving on to that
application and I believe it's over to
you again
Emma thank you
thank you chairman so this application
um is a variation of condition
application so um members of privacy
approved the development of the site for
the erection of six dwellings in this
location here so this is Fair Lawn Road
um to the south of this slide and you
can see there's a Northwood Road off to
the east side of this slide so the
original application was approved with
access into the site from Fair Lawn Road
but there was a condition attached to
the consent that said that during
construction works access to the site
should be from Northwood Road in this
location here so if you can see my
cursor this is the access that we were
expecting them to use for the
construction of the development
so this is just some aerial views
showing the site so the site's located
in this area here so this is Fair Lawn
Road in this location and again you can
see Northwood Road running along on the
right hand side here
and then a close-up view so again this
is the application site in this location
here
and again you can see it here so
historically there doesn't appear to
have been access into the site from Fair
Lawn Road so when I initially dealt with
the application and when it came in a
few years ago and I visited the site
there was just a fence that ran along
the boundary and you can see there was
trees in this location and you couldn't
appear to access the site from Fairlawn
Road and access the site appeared to be
from Northwood Road and so when I met
the the agent for site visits that's
that's the location of the access into
the site
so
um and this is the access from Northwood
Road into the site so this is the
existing access you can see for the
enlarged piece of the land with the
application site being off to the
left-hand side behind these properties
so this is now the access into Fairlawn
Road so when the previous application
was in some Works were carried out on
site they didn't require consent for it
because all they were doing was removing
the fence and putting in a gate so
they've created that access but then
since then we've granted permission
anyway and this would be the access for
vehicles into
um into the site to serve the six
dwellings with three on either side of
the road
so this is just a closer view of the
existing access now that runs from Fair
Lawn Road into the site
and from both sides and then you can see
this is Fairlawn Road so you can see
it's quite a narrow road when Vehicles
Park along here there is restricted
width on the road and this was the
concern that we had which led to the
condition
um seeking them to use the Northwood
Road access for the construction
vehicles so when putting that on high
KCC highways felt it was it would have
been preferred to have used the
Northwood Road Site because of the
narrow width of the access and from a
neighboring amenity point of view it was
also felt that would be useful so that
there weren't any concerns with blocking
entrances and things like that
so what what has happened since then is
the agent has come to us and advised
that they are unable to use the
Northwood Road access they don't have
legal access rights from Northwood Road
we've seen evidence of the land registry
plan for the site and it currently shows
that there's the only accesses from
Fairlawn Road they don't have a right of
way over any of the land onto Northwood
Road and the current owner of
um the site up to the north of the
application site has said that they will
not Grant access using Northwood Road to
the application site and therefore they
cannot build the development using the
Northwood Road access
in order to deal with the whether there
will be any impacts on the neighbors
from the use of Fairlawn Road as an
access during construction Works we've
requested them to submit a construction
management plan which they have done so
we've consulted KCC highways and we've
consulted environmental health for their
comments on this
so this you can see here this is a plan
that is the proposed or the layout that
we've previously approved for the six
houses
so you can see it looks it extends the
existing access and creates a turning
head at the end of the road and then a
parking area in the the far right corner
of the site
and this is just a closer view of the
approved scheme
so this is now the construction
management plan that's been submitted so
that they're looking to use the fair and
road to access the site they would
create the the vehicular access that's
been approved for the six units would be
created
um for the construction vehicles and the
area that would be used for parking to
serve the houses in the in the future
once they're constructed would be used
to provide parking spaces um during the
construction
um works with the site so it could be
used for some of the workers that come
to the sort of visitors to the site and
during the construction period
and this is a closer view just showing a
bit more detail so they're looking at
locating some of the um stores uh sort
of the office and the um
the welfare unit that will serve the
workers on the site these are going to
be located in in these locations here so
you can see the the green and the
the blue squares you can see again the
site parking in this location and then
the access located here
so in order to reduce any impacts on on
neighbors the construction management
plan can provide a number of details
that look to reduce uh reduce the impact
from the construction vehicles
so what they've included is that they
would provide 24 hours notice to
residents of deliveries
and that deliveries would only be during
10 a.m and 2 p.m on any day when the
road is most clear and doesn't have as
many parked cars and they're looking at
providing a display board at the site
entrance which would provide contact
details of the um of the company and
communication details so again if they
were intending to have a delivery to the
site and then that had to change those
details would be put on the board and
they've also mentioned the creek a
WhatsApp group with residents of the
street so that they can communicate with
them of any any changes again to to the
deliveries they're also looking at
restricting the size of the delivery
vehicles that would use the site and as
you can see with with this access they'd
be able to have construction vehicles
entering the site and turning they'd be
able to unload and then turn around and
exit the site again in a forward gear so
there shouldn't be any need for vehicles
to be parked within Fairlawn Road
blocking any driveways they should be
able to um
come into the site and turn unload and
leave again which should have limited
impact on residents
so KCC highways have have been consulted
with the construction management plan
and they've they've raised no concerns
with this and are happy with the details
that have been included
um in terms of the impact in terms of um
from dust and vibrations and things like
that with consulted environmental health
and they they've looked to the scheme so
what they're looking at doing is making
sure that any equipment's turned off
when not in use that any dust generating
equipments located as far from
boundaries with Residential Properties
as possible
um that a close-boarded fence is erected
along the southern boundary and the
eastern boundary of the site to help
um just to stop dust traveling over to
the neighboring properties and that also
help with noise as well
and to create an access gate that would
be locked to for safety purposes as well
um again they've also wanted the offices
in the welfare unit to be as far from
Residential Properties as possible which
in this far corner here they should be
so we've we've asked the
um the developer how long they expect
the construction Works to last and
they've said that they anticipate eight
to twelve months for the completion of
the the six units so the impact is is
very temporary so it should be no more
than a year of of these uh these
temporary impacts on the neighbors from
the use of this road
um so given the fact that
they can't use Northwood Road access and
they can only use this access and it is
allocated housing site and we have
approved the development of this site
for housing given the fact it is a
temporary impact on residents during
during this this year and hopefully not
much more than that and given the fact
they've done as much as they can to
mitigate the impact and their adequate
turning and parking within the site that
should reduce impact on neighbors
um and like I say there's other
limitations such as the the delivery
hours and making sure there is good
notice given to Residents it's
considered that it would be unreasonable
to amend the condition to allow for the
use of Fairlawn Road for Access for the
construction vehicles so it is currently
recommended for it to be deferred and
delegated subject to the legal agreement
to come back in so the SBA contribution
that we secured through the visual
application we need to secure again
through this application because we're
granting another permission so I think
they've just submitted that so we should
have that that shortly and so subject to
that being submitted and subject to the
safeguarding conditions that we
previously applied along with a
condition that now requires them to
comply with the construction management
plan it's recommended
um deferred and delegated for approval
thank you
uh thank you Emma as you've heard the
officers of recommendation
um
move that the officer's recommendation
is
I got
I have not received notification of the
charts there knows this
and I've found unfortunately on Monday
too late because I didn't have any
notifications only my neighbor no matter
I'm the one who's in number 11. that
road I'd just like to speak
I am sorry I do understand I I have been
it has been mentioned before we sat down
this evening that
obviously we don't know yourselves
personally but um that you had you know
applied and there is a time limit and so
forth as members know and we have to
keep to that I'm afraid
I do understand your concern but I
cannot allow you to speak
no
I don't think that's the case as I
understand it's a
um I will stop the conversation there
I'm not being rude to you I can't I
don't do that but
um our officer here has explained the
situation to me
before we started
and I'm quite happier the explanation he
has given me so I'm I'm sorry I can't
allow you to speak
uh moving back to this item agenda I do
move that the officer's recommendation
is adopted uh please Vice chairman could
you second
oh
thank you councilman cooker members
Council Ghana
thank you yeah I mean
this when this application came there
were a couple of things I want to say
about this when this application came
before us
um last March one of the things that was
highlighted was that the was the access
to the site off of Northwood Road
I think we I raised and it was and it
was discussed that this site
the other part of this site is owned by
a different company and I think we more
we more or less knew that the access was
not via land that was owned by this
developer it was via land owned by the
other developer that we hadn't been
told that they didn't have permission to
access over and we I feel like we've
almost
at that time approved an application
that was based on access from somewhere
else that we might may have thought
differently if it had been accessed via
Fair Lawn Road which is as can be seen
by it from the photos and the state of
that road and as can be seen by the
number of objections that have been
received by the residents in that road
and I think he's demonstrated also by
the number of
detailed conditions that have been added
to the construction management plan
which
go down to a very low level of detail
including something I've never heard of
a WhatsApp group with residents
um but you know if that's what's needed
then fair enough but
I feel like we've been
not applied for play this is our office
I wasn't meaning I wasn't going to go
that far but yes I feel like we have
been a little bit Hoodwinked into
approving this this this application on
its own
and as I said before there are there is
another application there is another
solution to this
you know there is another application
that will come before us and at some
point that will
if it's approved once it comes before us
then there will be there will be an
opportunity to for the both the
developments to be work together without
impacting some of these residents or all
of these residents who live in Fair Lawn
Road and I'd really am very
I'm happy about this
um and I will find it very very
difficult to to support this application
and I would be interested in hearing
what everyone else has got to say about
it
uh thank you councilman
viable but I feel that this construction
management plan is is very very detailed
and goes to Great Lengths to ensure that
residents are disrupted as little as
possible it is temporary
um these things happen I think it's
unfortunate but I really think to not to
enable this development for that reason
would be unreasonable so I'll support it
thank you thank you Council for Council
Everett
yeah I I use the word play to counsel a
Ghana and that's what it feels like to
me I mean
the developer is put in an application
which apparently they had no security
that they could actually deliver
in terms of the application that they
presented to us and we've given
permission for that development and I
think you know at the time I probably
voted for it and I I accept that it's a
it's a reasonable development on an
appropriate site but um the fact that
the developers now discovered that they
haven't got access to the site from from
the other out from the other road is
very convenient it seems to me I mean
the difficulty we got is I can well
understand that the resident's very
upset about it the difficulty we've got
is that I don't think that we can give
the disruption that coming down Fair
Lawn Road
um would cause
so much weight that we can refuse to
change the condition
so um I'm very unhappy about it and I
understand why the residents are unhappy
about it but the reality is if we resist
changing the condition I'm sure they'll
go to appeal and get it
um so we'd just be wasting everybody's
time
um thank you chair thank you for that
counselor Eric Council heart
please uh chair I agree with Council
forever I mean if if we I I don't
approve of this and I think that um we
have been
um misled I think on this planning
application
um as you all know I'm doing a small
extension at my house and uh it's
nowhere near Six houses being built on a
plot it's a small extension and I can
tell you how many Vans have been outside
my house it's unbelievable just to have
people turning up Tyler's to
electricians to Plumbers to pliers to
Rufus it goes on and on and on and
there's no way that all the vehicles
will fit in four spaces on that site
just to build six houses they will be
parking down that road both sides of the
road and blocking it that's my only
concern and that's my only issue I don't
think four four parking spaces is
sufficient for the for the workers to go
on site and
to be fair I I do agree with with
Council ever I think if we
I'm not happy about it at all in any way
shape or form and I think if it had come
before us they would have had to have
been more of a discussion about it than
there is now
um but
if we do not approve this I think it
will go to a poem we will lose and I
think that's right that's a shame in a
way because I think the disruption is is
is larger than people imagine thank you
chair now thank you councilor Hart um
Emma if you wish to come back for a
moment I
shouldn't just so you're aware it wasn't
that the developer
proposed through that application to use
Northwood Road as the access point when
the application came in we obviously had
a lot of concerns from residents lots of
objections with the use of the road
um so in order to try and address those
concerns of residents we looked at where
the Northwood Road access could be used
for the construction
um I mean to be fair on the developer he
did race-on concerns with it and wasn't
sure whether he'd be able to get get
agreement to use the access but it was
hoped that that was the case so we did
agree to the condition but obviously
since then the owner of the site has
said no he's not going to allow the the
use of that access so I don't think it
was that he initially proposed to use it
and then they'll come back to you saying
oh now I've got consent I'm going to
change it that was actually not
originally his intention we use we try
to get them to use that in order to try
and address the concerns from residents
but obviously hasn't worked because he
can't get that access over the land
and in terms of the other point you just
mentioned with the parking so this plan
here is is showing that
um that the referral Road itself
wouldn't be used for parking but you see
the blue dots that they've shown along
Cox's Lane and Northwood Road they've
shown on here that that would be um
potential parking to serve the site as
well so whilst I've got the four parking
spaces in the site if they needed any
additional parking it would actually be
along Cox's lane or Northwood Road but
not within Fairlawn Road itself which is
is more restricted through the um
construction management plan
uh thank you Emma um cancer Auburn
yeah thank you chair
um I'm in the not happy club uh that we
that's that's that's going here but also
need to uh we need to look at this in
Practical terms and um just to take out
some points that some my fellow
colleagues here have raised
um
Builders don't
comply
with being told to park 200 or
half a mile away from a site
uh they will part wherever they feel
like parking and who
is going to enforce that
when the builders say and as as
councilor Harter said you know when the
roofers the tilers or whatever turn up
and they decide to park in Fair long
road uh who's going to tell them to move
it because the site manager because
they'll just say well I'm going mate
um so you know they'll say oh we'll you
know
supposition I know but I think it's a
fair point and fair long road is very
tight
so I think there will be a lot of
problems here
I was going to ask a question but Emma's
partially answered the question in
relation to the previous access and
should we have asked them to get a
written consent that they can use it and
for that to come in with the application
because we were just assuming that they
would get it
just a question you know if you may want
to answer that or not as the case may be
however
regards to that
um
I think it's right what uh Council
Revenue counselor Hart have said in
relation to an appeal we wouldn't win an
appeal on this
so I'm in the as I said in the not happy
Club but I think I'm going to have to
vote in favor of the application thank
you chip thank you for that councilor
Auburn I'm going to bring back Mr
limousine
thank you chairman
um just to come back on the enforcement
point this was something actually came
up a couple of meetings ago the council
relatively recently has served a number
of breach of condition notices on
developers during construction
specifically relating to breach's
construction management plan in fact
we've got a current case where we're
potentially preparing a notice that went
in front of members not too long ago in
fact for similar sort of issues so we do
expect and we hope that if this
construction management plan is not
accorded with the residents will raise
it with planning enforcement because I
think we we will hold them to this
standard I can make that absolutely
clear in this forum I think just to come
back on your question with regards to
written
um sort of consent I mean I think that
yep in this sort of scenario I think in
the future then it it will be something
I think we'll need to get it's it is
rare that this sort of situation does
come up often sites will only have one
access point in reality uh and
fundamentally what we were trying to do
in this instance was to actually
alleviate some of the concerns of
residents and Fort is incredibly
unfortunate hasn't come off but I think
the important thing then is that this
construction management plan is accorded
with
um to avoid more disruption uh than the
necessary to construct the development
over this temporary period
thank you and Council Moore
yes thank you chair I think I think
we're all singing from the same hymn
sheet here
um I just wondered it the time scale for
the development you said eight to 12
months I presume that's for all six
houses
um but if it was a stage development
where they built maybe the first four
and left the top two plots three and
four out they could use that for hard
standing and park their vehicles
and then they would only need what
they've got for the last two it's just
to suggestion I don't know whether we
can do that or not but if we would
suggest maybe a stage development that
would mean the time scale be longer but
it might alleviate the vehicular
problems and tradesmans
I think it's certain more Ian it's not
obviously it's not in the construction
management plan but we can feed that
back to the developer
thanks
I don't see any other hand sorry
counselor gone I'll bring you back yeah
I just wanted to come back on a couple
of things
um
well I've yeah I've just noticed Cox's
Lane I mean I wouldn't be get too
carried away about that being a good
solution I mean that's not that much a
wide over a road than um Fairlawn Road
and if you're parking all the um
or the the builders cars in that lane
than any any lorries that are coming
along to turn into Fair Lawn Lane are
going to struggle they're all going to
be able to leave the site move their
cars come back to get it all in so
that's just one thing the other thing
I just want to re-emphasize the point
that this is a large potentially a large
development site because there is
another application for much larger
development on the site next to it and
there have been opportunities or there
should be opportunities for
developers to be able to work together
to make sure the development all takes
place away from Fair Lawn Road
you know that's just just a thought and
the last thing
I'm I I'm a little bit disappointed that
we
we as a committee seem to be driven by
what what we think and inspector might
decide if we were to if we were to go
with our opinion and vote that this is
the wrong application at the wrong time
for the residents in that road we should
we should stand up for what we believe
in rather than just preempt well we
don't like it but the inspectoral
overall it so we'll vote in favor of it
I think it's a bit of a shame but that's
my last point
uh thank you for that Council Carla uh
Council Shroff there is an empty
University car park around the corner
couldn't they Park in there and walk
around
the construction stuff
um I can stop there I think we're going
off subjects a little bit I do
understand councilor shrub but
we we've got to go we've got we have I
do understand councilor Hut you have to
come back thanks uh um councilman Garner
makes a a valid point
um
have we had a planning application for
the other site
and if so
um I assumed what you said earlier Emma
that the access for these properties was
to be from
um fan on isn't it Fair Lawn Road or
whatever it is
um whatever it is yeah um so that was
always the intended access to those
properties wasn't it
so they weren't really going to use that
other access to get into there so they
they still won't
what I'm saying trying to suggest is
when the other
buildings are put on the other area
is that going to be a highways road so
they could then use that as access or
will it be a private road and they can't
use that for Access is what I'm trying
to aim at because if it can be then
could this be delayed till that that is
actually built and then they can have
access from that
if you see your domain sorry uh I'll
speak account council's heart I do I I
go I understand what you're getting at
but we've still got to keep two this
application at the moment what's coming
in the future with other applications I
am aware of what you're saying you know
I've read and seen so
Emma I'm yeah just to respond to a few
of those points so there is a pending
application for the site in the north um
that I'm currently dealing with
um it has been called into committee so
members will see it when it's it's ready
to come forward but at the moment
um we're looking at a lot of amendments
on that scheme
um the layout that they've shown on that
plan at the moment is not showing any
form of Link Road with this road so Fair
Lawn Road would be sort of the end of a
cul-de-sac and that would be it and then
access to the other sites the north
would be from Northwood Road so there'll
be no link in terms of the roads there
has been a suggestion that if if that
site to the north comes forward and
members
um decide to recommend approval of that
scheme that it could be that maybe one
developer looks at both sites so whilst
we're putting this towards members
tonight to say
um you know we're looking to agree
um or recommend approval of the
variation the condition
um that's only if this site comes
forward on its own but it could well be
that it does come forward with the other
side to the north if that is approved
and that they would still continue to
use Northwood Road as the access for
construction works so this is just the
fact they don't they don't want to make
sure or they want to make sure that they
can develop this site on its own if they
needed to
um but it still means yeah there still
could be use of Northwood Road for
construction traffic in in the future if
the other site comes forward
um
I can't remember what my other point was
actually
[Music]
sorry I can't just jump in there
um I think that the point about holding
up this development
until another one comes forward is not
reasonable it's not a reasonable
judgment in any sense even though I
think I agree it would be ideal it would
resolve the problem but we can't hold up
this application on that basis it's
patently unreasonable behavior and we
would be affected appealed by on that
sort of ground thank you chair
uh thank you Ian uh councilman you wish
to come back yes chat um I'll just talk
um emphasize what Mr Liberty just said
if the other application did come
forward and it's a larger development
you're going to have more Traders and
more lawyers working on two areas at
once but as the application is not
before us and we can't take that into
consideration this one I think we just
need to talk about this one and move
forward
thank you
um
before I go to the councilor Auburn yeah
just to come back on the point of
councilor Garner made and I
um
hear what he's saying about the comments
that have been made that we would lose
that probably lose it on appeal if we
were to refuse it I think
obviously the points that we need to
take into account on on that and
certainly I have
is that the statutory Consultants are
all happy with it
um you know if they if they weren't
happy with it
you know or you know we that we would
have a problem so
um not just saying
saying it for the sake of saying it but
it's saying it on on the grounds that
there are no grounds not to consider an
appeal
thank you for that Council Auburn I was
about to touch on that as well but thank
you uh before I put this to the vote I
know we do have two residents so I'm
sorry I can't bring you in I know it
must be frustrating but I have to keep I
have to keep
like okay I don't embarrass you until I
just have to keep to the rules
and thank you for listening so I'm going
to put this to the vote uh members in
favor please show
against
any abstentions
no that is carried
thank you members uh that concludes uh
tonight's meeting uh thank you very much
for your attendance
um
and we will see you here you hit in the
next whenever thank you members